pas vrai wes images dans la rue crée
moins six voire beaucoup 1 mais qui
boite il va le voir lady bon bon bon bon
bon bon bon bon bonjour monsieur vous
vous vous battez oui bah oui ça se voit
comment ça se fait que vos boîtes et et
des bas parce que j'ai une jambe plus
longue que l'autre et j'ai une technique
beaucoup vous venez vous battez plus
bien beau mais c'est quoi la technique
et 10 et ça c'est très très très simple
vous vous mettez le pied le plus plus
plus le plus plu le plus court 6 sur le
tro tro trottoir vous vous le mettez n'a
normalement dont il le regarde et vous
voulez technique pour plus bégayer du
peuple et bla bla bla bla sur la ferme
ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes toujours
m
non j'ai des coups de fil toute la
soirée avec des gens qu'il faut nous
appeler j'ai répondu c'est bon ça ne
sonne plus allô allô allô qui est là à
l'eau michel bouchard michel tamatave à
ya le banc tellement même n'est pas ma
came à cette bordel mon chéri tu es où
et dans le sud de la france les
programmes ambitieux avec michel que
nous fait une blague téléphonique ce que
c'est on est ok c'est le sel pas du tout
manque
tu nous manques mais si l on t'aime
johnny mois ou 12 mois ou si vous ne
vous inquiétez pas alors vas-y parce que
tout le monde t'attend vas-y on est on
est là on t'écoute tout à wimille et ils
m'ont appelé pour me dire alors toi
c'est un jeune couple ils viennent de se
marier et et la femme elle est très
amoureuse de son mari fait ya très
longtemps l'un parce que à mon avis
aujourd'hui sa 8e plus du tout alors le
mari après après le voyage de noces et
tout ça tout ça s'est très bien passé
le soir le premier trois autres à la
maison la maison elle est propre elle
est impeccable et à sa femme qui
l'attend et mon amour tu as passé une
bonne journée vient regarder tout
préparé tout il lui dit ma chérie c'est
magnifique magnifique mais tu sais quoi
ma mère quand elle se rend de la maison
les chaises l'aimé comme ça le linge il
mais comme ça mais l'éclat appelle là
mais comme tu as elle dit bon d'accord
maïs en bas elle est un peu baissé mais
rj en plomb demain il arrive à la maison
elle a fait à manger tous les plats
qu'il est vraiment de l'amour et la
ghana où il ya un couscous des boulettes
merveilleuse mais une merveille de
merveilles la viande au petit thouars
des aînés marco tout l'accablé remplis
de nourriture ya à manger pour six cent
mille personnes
c'est ce qu'ils regardent aussi riche
c'est tout préparé il dit quelle
merveille mais quelle merveille
mais quelle merveille de femmes que j'ai
mais tu vois ma mère comme c'est le
couscous est c'est vrai comme ou tard à
la reine de rire quand on a mal mais
recaser devienne une boulette elle n'est
pas des boulettes comme tard et les
frais du wagon tas et andrew bynum 16
walid à l'intérieur sa femme elle en
minutieux et déjà elle a envie de tuer
la mère ou si l on peut plus et tous les
jours plus vous jouez y avait une fuite
le soir ils rentrent elle a réparé la
fuite tout seul avec des clés à molette
et tout est dit quelle merveille ma
chérie mais ma mère portait leur est pas
[Rires]
alors bruno bruel en bulles elle va voir
un psychologue et le cycle de la guilde
écoutez madame il ya un endroit où ta
mère on ne peut pas intervenir
tu es la chambre la chambre il est
imbattable
alors mettez le paquet est comme ça qu
après reggae il arrive le soir elle a
mis une chemise de nuit on tâte un noir
est l'ami débat magnifique noir des
porte jarretelles noir les draps en
satin noir
la robe de chambre qui la voit tout en
noir comme ça tu dis pourquoi tout noir
il est arrivé quelque chose à ma mère
[Applaudissements]
seul salon tel sort du sexe ou la burqa
dont nous avons un peu hautaine faure
michel aulas des remerciements
[Applaudissements]